I got a question for him it's a little
off the subject
I feel like Gusterson and heavyweight
and heavyweight would be a nightmare for
all of them okay I hopefully you know
with Dustin that's just how bad he wants
it you know here's all the town in the
world he'd be the best fighter pound for
pound of all time if DC and John Jones
were born I don't know yeah I know it's
just that before yeah you know so um
because it's heavyweight boy he's just a
pawn so you just got to hope that the
speed translates oh yeah ha you know you
know how we like to Luke Rockhold went
up to 205 yeah he looked so slow yeah
you gotta hold that yeah the speed comes
with him but you know but that do his
natural weight would I think lend itself
to being in shape I don't know I mean I
my lies natural enemies all my favorite
people in the UFC I hope it happens but
yeah that fights this weekend right chin
is he's he's on the hooker uh Dustin
Poirier card I'm not sure let me check
I'm almost positive he's fighting this
week this is parade number two four four
four two three or four
well he hasn't fought since copy he
might be three hmm is he not oh is he on
the July 11th card guys part of the
later one that card this Saturday's fun
though will watch in San Antonio I
wonder I would assume Gus wins uh let's
go to your favorite yeah you see five
five five five weeks like they're just
slinging about slang about loose mont
burns what's your calling that for you
somebody really yeah it's not popping up
huh no I'm just just covered it
she launched one night of July 25th oh
so we had some time what a great fight
though
oh yes gusting beats for Doom I mean
he's there crazy
yeah he's so talented man one of my
favorite people really okay oh great
great great guy so talented such a beast
a Viking superstar a Viking representing
I'm sure boards everywhere oh yeah
forget it
one of the most talented guys I've ever
seen man you told me that well tell me
he was just I know
just an him get ready for the Mitrione
fight because we're fighting the same
card he's fighting john jones ice white
man and same card to decide to train
together and I drove down to San Diego
Lex was with me Tony Jeffries came with
me and all these plans I go on their
first round he [ __ ] starches I mean
just a right hand from Sweden straight
to my face
oh then went three rounds after that
even though I was concussed and then
turned just like I I think we need to
call it that day see you man see your
honor Thanks oh then I was like you know
what I'll just I'll just wrestle him no
see you know how they go he hit me right
here I'm just gonna wrestle if deck well
no he's really good at that
yeah he said now you're not gonna take
in what I took way I said this when he
fought John my prediction was he's gonna
take John down sure enough he did I
didn't know he's that good of a wrestler
I did not know he was a monster a
monster
oh dude well suffice John so in spite of
all time
he's also he's huge he's huge John's
toughest fight of all time yes a lot of
people think you John that day yep first
fight second fight John J got knocked
down the second but T killed
yeah that's how good John is by the way
correct yeah they still don't know
what's going on with him got two
heavyweight well they got whether he
wants to he just wants the money they're
not paying violent no don't blame him
I'll tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
Oh [ __ ] business